ils veulent vivre leur rêve américain
un rêve auquel des milliers de migrants
croît à nouveau avec l'arrivée mercredi
prochain à la maison blanche de joe
biden la situation de la communauté lgbt
dans le pays ne nous permet pas de
rester
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de nous
rendre aux états unis en partie à cause
de la discrimination est en partie parce
que nos droits humains ne sont pas
respectées nous ne pouvons plus vivre
nous ne pouvons plus subvenir aux
besoins de nos familles il n'y a plus
rien à faire pour ce pays
c'est pour ça que nous fuyons vers les
états unis peut-être que nous pourrons y
avoir une vie meilleure plus de 2000 km
à parcourir à pied pour atteindre les
états unis à condition de passer la
frontière entre le guatemala et le
mexique mexico qui a averti qu'il ne
permettrait pas l'entrée illégale sur
son territoire de caravanes de migrants
des mots qui ne semble pas diminuer et
la détermination de ces milliers de
marcheurs hondurien nous ne voulons plus
vivre au honduras
il n'y a plus de travail pas de
possibilités d'emploi
nous partons donc parce que nous ne
voulons plus souffrir des candidats à
l'émigration qui fuient la violence et
la misère au honduras situation aggravée
par les dégâts causés par le passage en
novembre dernier de deux ouragans
le tout sur fond de récession économique
dû à la pandémie de coronavirus alors
beaucoup veulent croire que joe biden
apportera de grands changements en
matière d'immigration
aux antipodes de la politique menée par
son prédécesseur donald trump de temps
que c'était l'une de ses promesses de
campagne
le premier jour je vais envoyer au
congrès un projet de loi de réforme de
l'immigration afin de fournir une
feuille de route vers la citoyenneté
pour 11 millions d'immigrants sans
papiers qui contribue tant à ce pays
je promet également d'annuler le décret
de trump sur le bannissement des
musulmans non américains depuis octobre
2018 plus d'une douzaine de caravanes de
migrants ont quitté le honduras des
familles qui n'ont pas pu poser un pied
sur le sol américain
tout se sont heurtés aux milliers de
garde-frontières et militaires
positionnés à la frontière sud avec le
mexique